Has changed,
now it's different,
but it's difficult for me to compare it
with Pushkin's time.
My brother compared to with 60 s of last
century,
a 20th century because in that time
point in Russia wasn't,
I would say itself,
maybe those have,
uh,
your readers,
I don't know,
part of the audience who read in
Russian,
they remember,
uh,
that this fabulous line by you have to
shrink a,
a point in Russia is more than a point
or the point and either buy it or I see
bullshit.
Uh,
and I remember that generations were
fascinated with these more with this
expression,
but in a sense it's quite silly because
a carrot than Russia more than a
character or an Dunno our bread and
Russia more than Brad and star in Russia
more than the star.
He's so,
uh,
today poetry is not more than poetry
should be probably first period during
whole Russian history when poetry
occupies its own place.
White models.
I Degas,
uh,
like in a different culture.
It is.
So
from an point of view,
it's normal because point a,
when it appoints,
stands on the stadium and the crowds
shouting,
shout like,
I don't know.
They see,
they look at the gladiator.
It's a strange situation because
probably not
was because poetry today shouldn't bears
a
not it's own load.
It shouldn't,
as I said,
it shouldn't substitute
free newspapers,
uh,
as it could be free in general.
It shouldn't.
How to it entertained people.
It shouldn't,
it shouldn't
talk about,
I don't know.
Uh,
something's not illegal,
but something for beaten.
No,
it has to do its own job.
Then lane aim go.
I Dunno,
out of poetry is
to figure out what poetry,
ece in practical way
it is searching of the language always
each,
each poetry or in progress.
I mean,
which pull each bullet point is working
on it is part of this general and quite
ambitious a search of the language which
give may be in,
in case of success.
Uh,
and this could give,
do they put him herself and to the old
audience possibility to be closer to the
uh,
understanding or suggestion what the
point.
Describe the situation like these
because
okay,
today in today's Russia,
the points are in so
dangerous for those who keep powering
their hands.
So
it is with one hand with the other hand,
those who have
follower
in their hands,
they understand that the raw much more,
many of much more effective ways of
moderation of their relationships with
people and people of art as well.
And it's not so necessary to the
directress refresh represents to redress
people.
So unfortunately I cannot answer
directly to your question as you asked
me.
So I don't think that,
uh,
the poetry will in 10 or 15 years,
the poetry will be the only possibility
to see the truth to people know the
difference.
Different institutions and a,
not only poetry
develops everything because.